so we have the function f of X is equal
to e to the X over x squared and what I
want to do in this video is find the
equation not of the tangent line but the
equation of the normal line when X is
equal to 1 so we care about the equation
of the normal line so I encourage you to
pause this video and try this on your
own and if you need a little bit of a
hint the hint I will give you is that
the slope of a normal line is going to
be the negative reciprocal negative
reciprocal of the slope of the tangent
line
if you imagine if you imagine a curve if
you imagine a curve like this and we
want to find a tangent line at a point
it's going to look something like this
so the tangent line is going to look
like this a normal line is perpendicular
to the tangent line so normal this is
this this is the tangent line the normal
line the normal line is going to be
perpendicular to that it's going to Co
just like that and if this has a slope
of M then this has a slope of the
negative reciprocal of M so negative 1
over m so what that is a little bit of a
hint I encourage you to find the
equation of the normal line to this
curve when x equals 1 so let's find the
let's find the slope of the tangent line
and then we take the negative reciprocal
we look we can find the slope of the
normal line so to find the slope of the
tangent line we just take the derivative
here and evaluate it at x equals 1
so f prime of X and actually let me let
me rewrite this a little bit so f of X
is equal to e to the x times X to the
negative 2 I like to rewrite it this way
because I always forget the whole
quotient rule thing I like the power
rule a lot more and this allows me to
use the power rule
I'm sorry not not the power rule the
product rule this allows me to do the
product rule instead of the quotient
rule so the derivative of this F prime
of X is going to be the derivative of e
to the X which is just e to the x times
X to the negative 2 plus e to the x
times the derivative
of X to the negative 2 which is negative
2 X to the negative 3 power I just use
the power rule right over here so if I
want to evaluate when X is equal to 1
this is going to be equal to let me do
that in that yellow color I like
switching colors this is going to be
equal to let's see this is going to be e
to the first power which is just e times
1 to the negative 2 which is just 1 plus
E Plus e to the first power which is
just e times negative 2 1 to the
negative 3 is just 1 so e times negative
2 so let me write it this way so top so
minus 2 e and E minus 2 e is just going
to be equal to negative e so this right
over here this is the slope that is the
slope of the tangent line the slope of
the tangent and so if we want the slope
of the normal we just take the negative
reciprocal so the negative reciprocal of
this is going to be well the reciprocal
is 1 over negative even with the
negative of that so it's going to be 1
over e this is going to be the slope
slope of the normal line slope of normal
normal line and then if we an our goal
isn't just to the slope of the normal
and we have the equation of the normal
line and we know that the equation of a
line can be represented as Y is equal to
MX plus B where m is the slope so we can
say it's going to be Y is equal to 1
over e remember we're doing the normal
line here times X plus B and to solve
for B we just have to recognize that we
know a point that this goes through this
goes through the point x equals 1 and
when x equals 1 so when x equals 1 when
x equals 1 what is y well Y is e to the
first over 1 which is just e so this
goes to the point 1 comma e so we know
that when X is equal to 1 Y is equal to
e and now we can just solve for B so we
get e
is equal to e is equal to 1 over e is
equal to 1 over e plus B plus B or we
could just subtract 1 over e from both
sides and we would get B is equal to e e
minus 1 over e e minus 1 over e and we
could obviously write this as let's see
we could write this as e squared minus 1
over e if we want to write it like that
but we could just leave it just like
this so the equation of the normal line
so we could deserve our drumroll right
over here is going to be y is equal to 1
over e 1 over e times x plus b and b
plus b b is all of this
so plus e minus 1 over e so that right
there is our equation of the normal line